Ринок землі от-от відкриється, проте чи є ця земля якісним товаром?
Фермер Олексій Новохатько з селища Трипілля, що на Київщині, сумнівається.
Каже, через купу помилок в даних Держгеокадастру, багаторічної відсутності контролю
за використанням земель на місцях покупці можуть отримати у власність,
приміром, ось такий земельний пай в три гектари.
З одного його боку можна садити пшеницю, а з іншого боку мати величезний смітник.
Дві третини засипано сміттям. От цей точно ніхто не купить.
Власники мають бажання його продати, але притомна людина не купить.
Його можуть купити, але як один га.
Цей пай Олексій вимушений орендувати, тому що це кінець його поля.
Фермер запевняє, що подібних випадків на Київщині багато.
Паї проходять скрізь кладовища або приватні будинки,
хоча на віртуальних мапах Держгеокадастру потенційні власники
не завжди можуть це побачити, бо виправлені не усі помилки.
Сам Олексій через ці помилки, які багато років не хочуть чи не здатні виправити
земельні інспектори, теж не зможе продати свій земельний пай.
Земельна ділянка розміром в три га. Фактично в обробітку знаходяться два
по одній простій причині, що 50 метрів ось туди - в дерева, це також пай,
також сільгосппризначення. І до середини асфальтної дороги також моя ділянка.
От це вам якість підготовки межових знаків. Це дуже конфліктно і дуже недешево,
і дуже довго, поки цим ніхто не заморочується.
Але коли почнеться "земельний базар", це вилізе по-новому.
Історія земельного паю Олексія не поодинока. Інші дрібні, середні фермери
та великі компанії повідомили DW про те, що теж мають справу з паями,
які проходять крізь їхні корівники, склади, паї накладаються один на одний,
права власності дублюються тощо. Представники агробізнесу не виключають,
що у разі продажу таких паїв, вони можуть втратити або своє майно,
яке змусять знести, або ж вирощені культури.
Фермер Олексій в цілому виступає за проведення земельної реформи.
Вона давно вже назріла, але не в умовах такого "кадастрового хаосу",
який виник, на його думку, через брак якісної інвентаризації земель
з дублюючим контролем меж паїв на місцевості. З ним частково згодні
і представники агробізнесу-члени Європейської Бізнес Асоціації.
Я за те, щоб гарно презентуватися. За те, щоб не було накладок.
Можливо, радше було б спробувати на значно меншій кількості земель,
щоб відтестувати, відшліфувати, а потім максимально швидко розгортати.
Але якщо держава впевнена в своїх силах і бачить, що вони не мають таких-от проблем,
то нехай починає з 1 липня. Головне, щоб уникнути ґвалту і хаосу на ринку землі.
Але з іншого боку не помиляється той, хто нічого не робить.
Держгеокадастр намагається переконати селян та фермерів,
що в 2020-2021 роках був проведений повноцінний аудит земель,
принаймні було визначено, яка земля перебуває в державній,
а яка - в приватній власності. З урядових кабінетів також лунають обіцянки
вирішити проблеми, які виникатимуть в актуальному режимі.
У Верховній Раді, яка за два роки ухвалила купу земельних законів,
теж обіцяли оперативно реагувати, у разі необхідності ухвалити законодавчі зміни.
У все це фермер Олексій Новохатько не дуже вірить. Він працює на землі з 1991 року
і стежить за усіма земельними ініціативами усіх урядів. Чоловік зізнається,
що поки ретельно не проаналізував усі нові закони. Але глобально не довіряє реформі,
оскільки жоден з реформаторів поки не запропонував безпечну,
на його погляд, модель ринку. Його модель реформи - це коли землі
можна купити і орендувати в державному банку землі.
От цей плакатик, я з ним вже ходжу на різні земельні мітинги вже понад 3 роки.
Це відбулося не вчора, не сьогодні. Це питання і при Порошенку поставало
на початку його каденції, потім сором’язливо зняли з сайту, коли було багато звернень районних рад.
В принципі  торгівля земельними ділянками можлива, але на умовах Польщі або ФРН,
де існує ряд об’єктивних обмежень, які мають на меті формування
сильного фермерського класу, збереження податків в межах країни
і мають на увазі збереження цілісності держави. Україні це теж потрібно.
Позицію Олексія певною мірою поділяє і ще один фермер з Київщини Віктор Неділько.
Він має семеро дітей і господарює з усією своєю великою родиною з 2000 року,
обробляючи 170 гектарів землі. У Віктора поки немає довіри
до усіх запропонованих земельних новацій. Його бажана модель земельної реформи
- це коли держава передає всі землі ОТГ і ОТГ контролює, кому та що продається
та здається в оренду.
Закон проти українського фермерства, проти українського народу,
бо порядок в кадастрі не наведений, геть ні грама. Виходить так:
якщо цей закон увійде в силу, ми, селяни, залишимося без землі.
Великі холдинги скуплять цю землю, бо в нас грошей немає.
Він не дуже розуміє, як буде функціонувати ринок після 1 липня,
коли розпочнуться  електронні аукціони. Якщо власники паїв, які він орендує,
захочуть продати землю на аукціоні, то навіть попри те, що закон
гарантує йому першочергове право викупу (щоправда, за найвищою ціною),
він навряд чи на це пристане. Також він не розуміє політику держави
щодо так званих "фермерських земель", які видавалися селянам
на початку 2000-их в довгострокову оренду для фермерства.
В нього 50 таких гектарів. Відповідно до законодавчих змін,
вони мають бути передані в ОТГ і законодавчо держава гарантує фермерам,
які працювали на цій землі, першочергове право викупу чи оренди.
У Віктора та його сина Олексія, який навчається в аграрному виші,
немає впевненості, що договір подовжать або ж дадуть реальну можливість
викупити чи орендувати землі за пільговими цінами.
Ми їх, мабуть, не викупимо. Десь якісь дядя з Одеси з великими грошима
зайде в електронний реєстр, дасть більшу ціну і викупить. І все.
Ми залишимося без землі.
Вони її просто хочуть продати. Навіть і не так. Вони її вже покупляли багато
тих чиновників. А тепер хочуть узаконити. Ми будемо працювати,
будуть нас наймати, будемо працювати. Нам же треба десь працювати.
Такий скептицизм фермерів щодо земельної реформи і відкриття ринку землі
не поділяє експерт із земельних питань Дмитро Ливч.
Він запевняє: держава своїми новими законами нарешті дозволяє
власникам земель цивілізовано розпоряджатися своїми ділянками,
при цьому надаючи дрібним та середнім фермерам багато переваг.
А в Держгеокадастрі, земельних управліннях рано чи пізно зроблять
свою роботу належно. Більше того, експерт позитивно оцінює
законодавчу роботу уряду й парламенту для підготовки можливостей
пільгового кредитування для всіх учасників майбутнього ринку.
Є програма "5.7.9. Доступні кредити". Її умови будуть розповсюджені
на підприємства в агросекторі, а також на українських землевласників,
які, як і фермери, зможуть використовувати кредитні кошти для купівлі землі,
а також для купівлі основних засобів. Друге. Є Фонд часткового гарантування кредитів.
Це є співпраця уряду і Світового банку, щоб покращити доступ
до фінансових ресурсів. Нам  потрібно пережити момент запуску ринку землі
і підготувати населення  для подальшої лібералізації ринку, тоді доступ
до фінансових ресурсів буде покращено.
Щоправда, пільгові кредити будуть презентовані вже після запуску ринку землі.
Нині ж уже відомі попередні стартові ціни за гектар землі сільгосппризначення
- від 1200 до 1500 доларів. Фермери переконані, що ціни поповзуть вгору.
І навіть якщо буде доступ до пільгових кредитів, їм буде важко їх виплатити.
Земельні війни, які велися до цього, як каже фермер Віктор Неділько, "це були лише квіточки".
Мені здається, що автоматні черги будуть скрізь лунати, і ще "лимонками" дехто буде відстрілюватися.
Бо зараз воюють за оренду, а тоді, коли прийде "дика купівля",
бо вона не буде цивілізованою, як у людей, ми будемо захищати себе.
А що нам залишається? Воювати!
Земельна реформа вже два роки збирає різноманітні мітинги
під різними політичними прапорами. Аргументи проти продажу землі
часто зовсім не сумісні з ухваленими законами та економічною ситуацією.
Як, приміром, поширене переконання, що реформа зроблена
для великих агрохолдингів, які викуплять всю землю. Така можливість
їм дійсно надається, але лише з 2024 року. Тобто спершу основними
учасниками ринку будуть дрібні та середні фермери.
Як пояснює виконавча директорка Європейської Бізнес Асоціації Анна Дерев’янко,
у великих компаній, як і у дрібних фермерів, також немає вільних фінансів
для масової купівлі землі. Експертка переконана, що таких застережень
та багатьох побоювань могло б не бути, якби влада спілкувалася з населенням,
проводила роз’яснювальну роботу щодо етапів, умов та мети реформи.
Більшість протестів, на переконання експертки, пояснюються
недовірою населення до дій влади через високий рівень корупції
і неефективну систему правосуддя.
Зрозуміло, що  адекватний і незалежний ринок землі буде в нас
приносити фінансову свободу в нашій державі. Буде приносити іноземні інвестиції
і буде давати можливість заводити сюди виробництво
і продовжувати ланцюжок виробництва. Тому що ми зараз в багатьох випадках
експортуємо сировину, а бажано, щоб відбувався процес переробки
і для цього потрібно незалежне правосуддя, встановлення верховенства права,
а також працюючий ринок землі.
Аграріям слід готуватися відстоювати свої позиції, впевнена Анна Дерев’янко.
Олексій Новохатько та Віктор Неділько тим часом вже вираховують,
чи буде врожай цього року достатнім, щоб придбати землю на ринку.
Альтернатива -  пропрацювати ще кілька років на людських паях
до завершення терміну оренди і перекваліфікуватися. Олексій не виключає,
що займеться торгівлею. Віктор - сільгосппереробкою.
Зрештою обидва можуть заробляти гроші, працюючи на своїй техніці для інших.
Кажуть, що в результаті реформи багато дрібних фермерів, ймовірно, таки підуть з ринку.